I think it's hard to accept that if we
were to go into a different country and
say you guys are free to decide what you
want that they may install system that
number one doesn't work like do we go
back then and fix it and also they may
Pick A system that we don't like right
like if communism is what ultimately
Cuba decided would work I'm not saying
it did but that was what came out on top
when they were allowed to pick
you know
I would not if I were you know John
Kennedy or whatever I would not want to
be like ah yes Cuba you just have your
communism and hang out over here while
we have democracy but on the other hand
you just keep going in and saying like
no you have to do it our way you have to
do it all right you have to do it our
way especially like we were saying
before if there are countries that are
dominated by cultural or religious
pressures that are so dissimilar to what
we were founded on like we don't have
the same kind of basic needs that other
other civilizations do